[Music]
outside
that window display i'm so
sorry i can explain that
sorry baroness um get her
choose the vandal who messed up a whole
window display
we're dealing with it
so she works here no no she was fired
yeah
we're trying to give these wretches a
chance but um
breeding need i say more
so she doesn't work here
you're sweating and i can smell you
really
thank you you
grubby girl jeffy cart
cold
[Music]
you're hired this address 5 a.m
[Music]
as usual
here's to me
dear light
[Music]
get her who are you
you look vaguely familiar
i look stunning i don't know about
familiar darling
your hair is it real like my ball
i like to make an impact
right what was your name
cruella oh
that's quite fabulous and you designed
this you did
actually 1965 collection oh no wonder i
love it it's mine
i fixed it
oh we need that
well i was hoping there's a plan c why
what's plan c so what what i'm saying is
is there a plan say
get it
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my dog
[Music]
stella it's been so long
you know i kept staring at you at the
party and then it came to me
that's a stella from school it's not a
stella
that's the past i'm cruella
so you you go to parties and you take
pictures and you print gossip that's
your
job yes well not as fun as it sounds
oh it doesn't sound fun it sounds useful
oh
i'd like to start my own label
why don't we work together to create
some buzz for this old
rag that you continually fill with that
old hag
let me give you some advice you can't
care about anyone else
everyone else is an obstacle
you care what an obstacle wants or feels
you're dead
if i'd cared about anyone or thing i
might have died
you have the talent whether you have the
killer
instinct is the big question
she thought she owned everyone that's
foolish unhinged
well you're fired why are you speaking i
think you mixed me
but there's something about poetic
justice that's just so
poetic you won't admit you
[Music]
this doesn't have to be a scene it
really really does
i'd like to remind you all that i'm
doing this in hills
what was your name
[Music]
i want to make trouble you in i do love
trouble
you have a bit of an extreme side yes
darling
what fun that is
she stole my dogs
i guess you must hate her she has made
it me or her
and i choose me
don't worry there's lots more bad things
coming perhaps
perhaps
the overnight
[Music]
the sheer luck of a movie like this is
that the
costumes do a lot of your work for you
as an actor
once you put those things on you feel
like cruella deville
fashion was omnipresent in this film so
we got academy award winner jenny bevin
she's done it all
cruella and the baroness are adversaries
in their work
the baroness is at the hype but
fashioned in the 1970s how is krell
gonna disrupt the establishment
[Music]
this film is the biggest thing i've ever
done emma stern had 47
looks it was very important to me
for cruella to be black white gray and
red
i want to make art and i want to make
trouble
[Music]
to first see the entire look of cruella
together
i have to admit i took a lot of pictures
[Music]
it was a very narcissistic day
[Music]
which is perfect for cruella we'll just
have to destroy her as we have so many
before
find her
the baroness i saw very clearly it's
very sculptural
dior influenced sort of channeled
the old screen divas joan crawford
to elizabeth taylor every single costume
i go this is my favorite
oh no no this is my favorite
jenny has created something really
special
i'm starting to
you have a remember of an extreme side
[Music]
you